didier de mu est agriculteur depuis
1984 avec son épouse et son beau fils il
s'occupe d'une exploitation de 190
hectares principalement ce sont des
céréales c'est à dire dans la région
cultive surtout du blé de l'orge du maïs
est un peu d'eau les génies c'est-à-dire
colza et et féveroles cultures
céréalières mais pas seulement à la
ferme de changarnier vite un troupeau de
25 têtes dont 13 vaches allaitantes
aujourd'hui on fait un peu de
diversification plus qu on vend notre
viande au grand public sous forme de
colis et
ils viennent chercher leur viande à la
faire danser ce qu'elle a cachée très
intéressant pour des citadins dans la
région on est très peu on est plus
beaucoup à faire de l'élevage il reste
encore des mohicans qu'on va dire didier
de nuit et son épouse vous feront
découvrir leurs activités goûter les
produits issus de leur troupeau et même
participer à des balades à dos d'âne ils
vous attendent le samedi 15 et le
dimanche 16 octobre dès 10h